-Hello, and welcome back
to the captain's quarters.
It's Monday, which means my hair
has had another weekend to grow,
and while I'm
aiming for the Steff,
James Spader's iconic haircut
from "Pretty in Pink,"
I might be backing
into James Van Der Beek's
'do from "Dawson's Creek."
Now, I've never seen
"Dawson's Creek."
I didn't even know
it was a TV show.
I just assumed it was a meme
that best exemplifies
how I feel all the time.
But my wife is a "Creek" freak
who is currently rewatching it
on her phone every night in bed,
and I have
one big observation
based on my introduction
to the show.
The other characters
say "Dawson" a lot.
Like, even when it's
a two-person scene,
they start every sentence
with "Dawson," and, look,
Joey, Jen, I'm not telling you
how to live your life,
but he knows
you're talking to him.
There is no one else
in the room.
Also, Jen, everyone knows you
used to live in New York City.
Let it go.
Did you watch "Dawson's Creek,"
Sea Captain?
-I'm Team Pacey.
-Of course you are.
Now where were we?
Oh, right, the real world.
As the coronavirus pandemic
continues to spiral
out of control,
a morally and intellectually
bankrupt Republican Party
is squabbling over
cutting unemployment benefits
for out-of-work Americans
while sending secret police
to American cities
and whining about cartoons.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
And I am glad it's time
because...
♪ I don't wanna wait ♪
♪♪
-We're less than 100 days away
from the presidential election
and more Americans now say
that the country is
on the wrong track
than at any point
in Donald Trump's presidency.
We have got an out-of-control
pandemic,
the worst unemployment
in nearly a century,
an epidemic of racist
police brutality,
and a looming eviction crisis.
But don't worry.
The Trump administration
will protect your cartoons
and your toys.
-He is also appalled
by cancel culture,
and cancel culture specifically
as it pertains to cops.
We saw a few weeks ago
that "Paw Patrol,"
a cartoon show about cops
was canceled,
the show "Cops" was canceled,
"Live PD" was canceled.
Lego halted the sales of their
Lego City Police Station.
-"Paw Patrol" and Legos
make sense,
I guess, coming from a guy
who loves rockets,
trucks, and Mr. Potato Dead.
Anyway, I guess we know now
what Trump does
with all that free time
on his schedule.
"I don't like this
recycling pup, Rocky.
I think he's part
of the deep state.
Kayleigh!
Kayleigh, send the secret police
to Adventure Bay.
And get me some more Legos,
Kayleigh.
I stuck one up my nose
to stop the coronavirus.
Fauci, by the way, did you get
my email about Legos up the nose
maybe stopping the virus?
Okay.
I love your thoughts on that.
You're my best friend, Fauci.
You know what I call us?
'Turner and Fauch.'
I'm going to make t-shirts."
Anyway, this is where
the Trump administration
and the Republican Party are at,
whining about cartoons and Legos
while sending secret police
to gas moms and vets
and arguing that slavery
was a, quote, "necessary evil."
A sitting United States Senator
said that.
At least I think Tom Cotton
is a Senator.
He looks like
the Confederate Slender Man.
Seriously, these guys just keep
coming up with winners.
I mean, what's next?
Is Trump going to say
something nice
about an alleged sex
trafficker and predator
who was arrested by the FBI
at a remote -- oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, right.
They really think Americans care
about "Paw Patrol" and Legos.
I guess they figure
if you're out of work
and quarantining at home
to avoid the deadly virus
they failed to stop,
you'll need something
to keep you entertained.
"President Trump is working hard
to make sure
that out-of-work Americans
who lost their health insurance
and are facing eviction
have cartoons
and Legos
to keep them occupied.
And in lieu of the $600
unemployment benefit,
we will be sending
every American some Play-Doh
and an out-of-work
Tamagotchi.
And I'm sorry?
The Tamagotchi has died
from the coronavirus."
The craziest part of this though
is that she's wrong.
Neither "Paw Patrol"
nor the Lego City Police Station
have been canceled.
In fact, "Paw Patrol"
actually had to tweet
a clarification saying,
"No need to worry.
'Paw Patrol' is not canceled."
And that's great.
But, you know, they could also
stand to be defunded a little.
I mean, that's an awful lot
of tactical gear for a town
where the worst thing that ever
happens is a missing chicken.
So the Trump administration
got fact-checked
by a children's cartoon.
And at this point,
it's not long before
Arthur shows up to a protest
with a sign
that says "[Bleep] Trump."
-Seth, that reminds me,
what's a sea captain's
favorite animal?
-Oh, I don't know, what is a sea
captain's favorite animal?
-An arrrr-dvark!
-Sea Captain!
-Ha, ha, ha!
Sorry.
-So what was I talking about?
Oh, right.
Children's cartoons.
The point is this is what your
government was talking about
as a federal moratorium
on evictions
and a $600
unemployment benefit
keeping millions of Americans
afloat both expired.
And rather than rushing
with extreme urgency
to extend both programs,
or, heaven forbid,
make them permanent,
Republicans chose
instead to dawdle
as they bickered over ways
to make the unemployment program
both less generous
and more complicated.
Mitch McConnell said
a new stimulus deal
could take a few weeks.
Why?
Just extend it now.
Jobless claims went up
for the first time since March,
four million Americans who do
have jobs have seen a pay cut,
12 million are facing eviction
as the moratorium expires.
In Oklahoma, more than 60%
of unemployment applications
haven't even been processed,
with hundreds of people
sleeping in their cars
or camping outside
Oklahoma's unemployment offices.
And in Ohio, the city
of Columbus
has turned part of
its convention center
into an evictions court.
Well, you got to give it
to Trump,
he finally filled an arena.
Oh, and on top of that,
nurses are wearing gowns
without openings for hands
and secret police
are marching through the streets
of Portland tear-gassing vets
and moms while protesters
play the Imperial March
from "Star Wars."
[ Imperial March plays ]
[ Firing ]
[ Bursts ]
[ Firing continues ]
♪♪
That's a pretty great troll.
Of course, if George Lucas
was involved,
he'd probably add
in some unnecessary CGI
and a gratuitous pod race.
So what was the president doing
while the nation was crumbling?
You guessed it.
He was playing golf and smiling
for photos with Brett Favre.
Cheeseheads always loved Favre,
so it makes sense that
ol' cheese brain would, too.
Also, what's going on here, man?
He looks like he just crawled
out of a vat at Ace Chemicals.
This is how a dog smiles
when they have their head
out the window.
That's the face you make
when you're trying to hold in
a fart at a funeral.
Not that I think Trump would
bother trying to hold it in.
"Whoa, whoo!
Well, boy, if that doesn't wake
him up, he's definitely dead."
Although in fairness,
it's probably better
when Trump's golfing
because then he's too busy
to whine about cartoons
and Legos and statues.
This bottom-of-the-barrel
culture war bull [bleep]
is the result
of a political movement
that is intellectually barren
and morally bankrupt.
They have nothing to run on,
no policies to champion,
no achievements to tout.
So they think they
can get voters
to care about statues
and cartoons.
It's all they have left,
and that's because Americans
know Trump has failed.
It's clear in poll after poll.
All you have do is look at one
of the dozens
of other large
developed countries
that have successfully
suppressed their outbreaks
while keeping their economies
largely intact.
South Korea had its first case
on the same day as ours
and rapidly
contained their outbreak.
The entirety of the EU,
with a much larger population,
has an average of just 81 deaths
per day while we're at 1,000.
Americans can't even go
to Canada or Europe,
which means for the first time
this century,
no one will take a picture
trying to make it look like
they're holding up
the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
Americans can plainly see
that things are not just bad,
but getting worse while
the rest of the world
watches us with a combination
of pity and horror
and probably a little less
surprise than we think.
[ French accent ]
"It is so sad
what is happening
to your country."
[ Normal voice ] "I know,
it's shocking, right?"
[ French accent ]
"Yeah, eh, shocking?
I would not use this word.
It is -- how do you say?
To be expected."
We've seen our outbreak spiral
out of control
in a way that's even worse
than the initial peak in April.
The White House
National Security Advisor
just tested positive.
Major League Baseball
has an outbreak
just days
after starting its season.
We're nearing a national peak
in hospitalizations.
We recorded 1,000 new deaths
a day for four straight days.
And labs across the country
are once again
facing long delays in testing
thanks to supply shortages.
Or, as one public
health official put it,
"It's like 'Groundhog Day.'
I feel like I've lived this day
four or five months ago."
Except in "Groundhog Day,"
Bill Murray learned
to play the piano
and became a better person.
All I've learned is that doing
a late night show in your attic
is kind of like
making a video will,
except I am not of sound mind.
-Sure you are.
-Thank you, talking
yard sale painting.
Quarantine has lasted so long,
I've come full circle
and started watching
"Tiger King" again.
Gonna give Joe Exotic
one more chance
to convince me I'm wrong.
If you asked me what day
it is right now,
I'd say
Januaugustober 67th.
The only concrete day
I can picture
is the first day of school,
and I'm terrified
it's not going to happen
because instead of making a plan
on how to get kids
and teachers back safely,
we prioritized opening
a Crunch Fitness in Gainesville.
I hope you fellas got
swole enough
to make up for the fact that
my kids can't count past seven.
Seriously, we should have had
testing figured out months ago.
That was the whole point
of flattening the curve,
to buy time
for our policymakers
to get a system of testing,
tracing, and isolation in place
so we could contain
future outbreaks.
Remember that?
When we all kept saying
"flatten the curve"?
Back when Dr. Fauci
was the one briefing the nation
at press conferences
instead of chucking a ball
like your grandpa used to?
"I'll go get it, Grandpa."
"Look both ways when you
cross the street."
And yet, the President
and the GOP
have shown zero interest
in fixing the problem.
In fact, Trump is so deeply
invested in his own
political fortunes
and so profoundly
detached from reality,
that he still thinks
it would be better
if we stop testing altogether
and just let the virus
rip through the country
sickening people undetected.
-I personally think
it's overrated,
but I am totally willing
to keep doing it.
I'm okay with it
if they want to do it,
but again, it makes us look bad.
But think of it.
If instead of 50 million
we did 25 million,
we don't have
the number of cases.
The cases would be down.
Here would be
the normally headline.
Not for me it wouldn't be.
But for anybody else, they'd say
"Cases cut in half."
-For the millionth time,
that's not how it works.
The headline wouldn't be
"Cases cut in half."
At best, it would be something
like, "Cases cut in half
but everyone mysteriously
coughing for some reason!"
Second, it doesn't just
make you look bad.
It is bad.
The cases are there making
people sick in the real world
whether you test
for them or not.
Just because you refuse
to go to the dentist
doesn't mean
you don't have cavities.
All we have to do
is look at your face
to know you just took
a swig of ice water
with a mouth full
of rotten teeth.
And you can just sense
their desperation
as they grasp wildly
for arguments
even they must know
are absurd.
Take for example White House
senior policy advisor
and Edgar Allan Poe villain
Stephen Miller.
[ Thunder ]
[ Witch cackling ]
-Arrgh, be gone,
foul sea serpent.
To the last,
I grapple with thee!
From hell's heart,
I stab at thee!
For heat's sake,
I spit my last breath at thee!
-Sea Captain, what did I say
about Ahab references?
-Ah, well, you said
don't be a Moby Dick.
What are you doing, Seth?
-I'm just waiting for everybody
to finish laughing.
-Ha-ha, okay!
-As a raging pandemic
spiraled out of control,
Miller went on human money clip
Tucker Carlson's show
and compared the people
pulling down
Confederate statues
to Confederates.
-The Democratic Party
for a long time, historically,
has been the party of secession.
What you're seeing today
is the Democratic Party
returning to its roots.
These are mayors and governors
that are saying
the Federal Law,
the U.S. Constitution,
doesn't apply within
the confines of our city.
And our citizens will be
held at the mercy of the mob.
And the administration
of justice,
the federal courthouse, will be
allowed to fall under siege.
And that's what's happening
right now in Portland.
-So I guess that means
Stephen Miller wants
to build statues
to Democratic politicians?
Cool, where do you want
the Joe Biden statue?
How about on the Acela, or maybe
on the debate stage with Trump?
It probably wouldn't make
much of a difference,
since I'm pretty sure Biden's
approach to the debates
is gonna be what's known
in oratorical circles
as the statue strategy.
Just stand as still as possible
and let Trump say
a bunch of crazy things
and melt down on his own.
"They want to take away
your Legos, your 'Paw Patrol,'
your Beanie Babies,
your 'Yo Gabba Gabba!'
But we're not going to
let that happen, folks.
You can trust your
very normal president."
Seriously, you're calling
Democrats secessionists?
You guys are the ones
protecting the monuments
of actual secessionists.
Did they not teach history
at your grave robbing school?
The Confederates
you're defending
were racist slavers and traders.
You should know all that.
Since you were alive for it,
I'm pretty sure
when Lee surrendered
to Grant at Appomattox,
Miller was there
popping out of his coffin.
The GOP is totally
and completely bankrupt,
both morally and intellectually,
and with less than 100 days
before the election,
they're desperate.
150,000 Americans have died,
jobless claims are up again,
an unemployment lifeline and
eviction moratorium have expired
and they're talking
about cartoons.
Not only is the country
in dire straits,
but all of this --
-Makes us look bad.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
-Dawson!
♪♪
-So many New Yorkers are turning
to City Harvest
for help
feeding their families,
and they need your support
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.